the uba's are moving from houston to
egypt they pack their belongings in
rectangular crates and hire a boxcar to
ship the crates across land and sea
the crates are made specifically to fit
inside the boxcar with their bases
facing down
each crate has a base 5 meters long by
1.5 meters wide so let me draw that so
each crate is 5 meters long
and 1.5 meters wide 1.5 meters wide and
has a height of 2 meters so its height
might look something like this
so it has a height of 2 meters so that's
each of the crates
and they're designed they're designed to
fit inside a box car so this is a crate
right over here do my best to draw a
crate and they give us the dimensions of
the boxcar a boxcar is 15 meters long so
let me draw a box car here
so it's 15
meters long maybe i'll try to make sure
i can fit it on the page so this whole
distance would be five meters
and then another five meters here and
then another five meters here so that
would be 15 meters long
so you could fit you could fit three of
the crates along an edge
like that
three crates along an edge like that
and then they tell us that it is three
meters wide so this is 1.5 meters wide
so you could put two of these to get you
to three meters
three meters wide let me draw this so we
can see what's going on behind the
scenes so you could go three meters wide
for a box car and it is four meters high
so each of these are two meters high
each of these are two meters you could
stack one up one more
you could stack one more and so you have
two meters plus two meters this entire
distance
this entire distance right over here is
going to be four meters and i could draw
the rex rest of the box car like this
like this
so there's a couple of ways to think
about how many crates you could fit in a
box car one way would be just the way
that we're doing it right now we could
visualize how many can you fit in this
direction along the length how many can
you fit along the width and how many can
you fit along the height and you would
have essentially if we multiply those
three numbers we would have counted the
number of crates that could fit inside
so you could fit one
two three along the length so that'd be
three you could fit two along the width
one point five and one point five gets
you to three meters so times two and
then you could fit two along the height
so times two gets us two 3 times 2 is 6
times 2 is 12. you can fit 12 crates in
the boxcar
now another way you could have done it
is you could say okay they're telling us
that these are designed to fit so we
really just have to compare the volumes
how many times more is the volume of the
boxcar than the crate i like doing it
this way more just to make sure that the
dimensions actually work out so that you
can actually squeeze these in because if
the dimensions aren't right even if the
even if the boxcar is 12 times the
volume of one of the crates if the
crates don't have the right dimensions
you might not be able to squeeze exactly
12 crates in there but they're telling
us that it is the exact dimension so we
could figure out the dimensions of the
box car then the dimensions of the crate
and we can figure out how much larger
the boxcar is how many times larger so
the boxcar let's do the boxcar in this
blue color the boxcar is 15 meters long
three meters wide and four meters high
so boxcar
boxcar
volume
volume is equal to 15 and cubic meters
so this is 15 meters
times 3 meters times 4 meters so this is
going to be in cubic meters so this is
going to be you see 5 15 times 3 is 45
45 times 4 is 180 180 cubic meters
cubic meters that's the boxcar volume
and then what's the volume of the crate
well the crate volume
crate
volume
if we do our math right it should come
out to 1 12 of this because that's what
we just figured out is 5 times 1.5 times
2.
so 5 times 1.5
times 2.
well 1.5 times 2 is 3 times 5 is 15. so
cubic meters so how many times larger is
the boxcar than the crate
well what's 180 divided by 15. well it's
exactly 12.
10 times 15 is 150 and then 2 times 15
is 30 150 plus 30 is 180. so notice 180
divided by 15 is 12. so either way
however you think about it i find this
one to be a little bit easier to kind of
just visualize the boxes you can fit 12
crates in the boxcar